so excited to have these people with us
today I'm honored to be standing up here
with them and I'm going to introduce
them to you right
now starring as Jacob Kowalski who is
the first nomad who you may know as a
muggle to be a leading character in one
of the films from The Wizarding
Wizarding World Dan
fogler starring as the beautiful and
warm-hearted Queenie Goldstein a witch
who can read minds Allison
[Applause]
sudall the incredible award-winning
director at the helm of fantastic beast
and he also directed the final for Harry
Potter Blockbusters David
Yates she is the reason ultimately that
we are all here she is the creator of
The Wizarding World and that world also
changed our world forever she is a
producer on this film and she is also
making her screenwriting
debut JK
Rowling it's such a big deal to be in a
room with JK Rowling if she stays
upright yeah
yeah starring is the courageous and
compassionate Wizarding World mag
zoologist NES Commander one of the
nicest men in Show Business Eddie
redm the Oscar nominated producer of all
eight Harry Potter films which Remain
the top grossing film franchise of all
time he'll be ping out money after we're
after we're done of course he is a
producer on fantastic Beast David
hman starring is the Smart determined
and compassionate witch Tina Goldstein
your Leading Lady Katherine
Waterston
he stars as the mysterious young man
Credence barebone in the film and he may
know more about the Harry Potter
Universe than anyone on this day is with
the exception of one person
yeah Ezra
Miller I think we're getting a quick
photo and then you can all take your
seats and then we'll get
started do we do we
look thank
you yay well first first I want to
congratulate everybody and thank you for
the film and it is again really fun to
be here um I'm going to kick off with a
few questions before we uh before we go
to all of you and the first question is
of course for Joe Rowling hi
hi tell us tell us please when you
started to think that you wanted to
revisit this on the big screen revisit
the World of Harry Potter on the big
screen and why did you decide to do the
screenplay
yourself
um I knew that Warner Brothers wanted to
do something with Fantastic Beasts they
ad optioned it a long time
ago and and when I wrote the little book
that I wrote for charity the character
of new appealed to me and has often
happened with the PO verse I I had some
thoughts about what had happened to new
and who who new was and I don't think at
that stage I ever imagined writing a
screenplay then when Warners came to me
and said they they did now want to do
something with fantastic Beast I thought
no wait a moment wait a moment um I'd
better tell them what I've got because I
wouldn't want them to get n wrong cuz I
knew I liked n and then uh before I knew
it I'd actually written a I'd written it
I sat down to write some notes and then
I wrote a story and then that story
became a screenplay so that so it it it
was never really a calculated I think I
want to revisit the world it it came the
way these things always do through a
story and uh with obviously doing a
screenplay very different medium
different than than a novel um did did
you read books on screenplay writing did
uh people help you I did buy a book that
I never
read I just sat on my desk and I don't
really know I think I felt like that was
my homework but I hadn't actually done
my homework maybe I just thought I would
absorb it somehow by it ly by my by my
buy i w I was very involved with the Pod
of scripts in as much as I had script
approval and I spoke a lot to Steve
Clover about what he was doing so he I
would say that Steve was my tutor on
this and it's a reason that I was so
Keen to have him attached to this
project because I knew he would be the
guy I could phone at 4:00 a.m. if I
needed to I never phoned him at 400 a.m.
but I suppose I could have done I think
he would have been okay with that you
could if you wanted to I'm just saying
well just to be horrible yeah just to
wake him up he has to take your call no
matter what no it's not no I wouldn't do
it just because I could I would have to
be pretty desperate to phone him at 4:00
a.m. in um in in all of the Harry Potter
films we of course know the characters
before we see the film because we've
read the books in this particular case
we are meeting these characters for the
first time so I want to ask and I'll
I'll um I'll start with Dan on the end I
want to ask all of the actors to just
tell us a little bit about your
character tell us a little bit about
Jacob Kowalski who is he
wow I haven't done this in front of
her I'm taking notes yeah oh jeez okay
so Jacob's back from World War I and all
he wants to
do is settle down and open up a bakery
and and he gets mixed up with these
witches and
wizards and I it's a lot
like I equate it to uh like bottom from
mid summer night dream or you know I
grew up with Where the Wild Things Are
Max you know he goes to you know bottom
gets to go into the forest play with the
magical creatures and he falls in love
with tatan you know and that's what she
she Joe does so well she's it's in the
zeist already you know these characters
are iconic archetypical Heroes Journey
kind of I'm the Baker from the fairy
tale you know what I mean and
um that's
him Alis sudal was beautiful I
like Alison sudall tell us about
Queenie I'm equally nervous um Queenie
is is uh the most delightful human being
um she is she is warmhearted she is um
full of love and light she's so
accepting uh
these these two sort of Rascals walk
into their apartment uh a criminal and
uh Nomad which is totally not allowed
and she makes some
dinner um she's she is um she's lovely
insided out but she also has this this
ability that makes her particularly
special which is that she she reads she
reads minds but it's not just reading a
person's immediate thoughts she is
reading a person's story she's reading
into them the more that she tunes into a
person the more that she sees she's
she's this extraordinary empath and uh
it's a gift that that comes in handy uh
quite a bit in this film but also just
has has given her a really interesting
quality because while she is so so
loving and outgoing um she's she's
always looking out and she's always
receiving and that that's actually made
her a tiny bit um isolated in a in a in
a certain way it's kept her very pure
because she's had she's been protected
mainly by her sister really uh Tina
she's allowed to she's been allowed to
stay pure but yeah she's a wonderful
character I I love her very
much Eddie tell us a little bit about
n's
schander uh so I play n scander who is
um a self-proclaimed mag zoologist and
he was he attended Hogwarts he was
thrown out um under slightly
questionable circumstances and he is
passionate about creatures so in the
magical world at this
period magical creatures because
sometimes they're they're deemed
uncontrollable or um they have erratic
Behavior Behavior the Wizards can't
necessarily understand they give away
they could give away that Wizards exist
and he he is incredibly compassionate
and and a loving man and he loves them
and believes that they're misunderstood
so he has spent the year at the
beginning of this film um in the field
in Equatorial Guinea and all around the
world finding saving and learning about
magical creatures and they live some of
them in his case and um um but what I
love about n is he is
um he's not he's not very good with
human beings um or with Wizards he can't
really he doesn't have a particular
social capacity um but he is formidable
with his creatures and when he arrives
at the beginning of this film he arrives
in New York he scrutinizes this
landscape as if it were an ant's nest
and um but he feels very content in his
own skin and doesn't really feel the
need for other people and so he's a bit
prickly and naughty and not necessarily
someone that you instantly go up and
sort of warm to but through finding
these people these other Outsiders which
is what Joe writes so sensationally is
they bring out qualities in each other
and they better themselves um through
coming together and uh that's kind of
who
new Catherine what about Tina yeah poor
and Tina
I love saying it so her full name is
porpentina Goldstein and she's queenie's
older sister and they were orphaned as
children and she because she was the
elder sister sort of had to take on
um probably very adult position she
wasn't quite ready for and as a result
she's
um she's uh very capable and confident
in some ways and in some Arenas and like
new
she um thrives in certain aspects of her
life areas of her life but other parts
of her are quite
stunted um and because she never she
never had that opportunity to really um
be a child and kind of explore herself
um and so
she's probably before the film started
she was all business and very dedicated
to her job because that was was the area
of her life that worked um but right
before the beginning of the film she's
been demoted at work so when you first
meet her she's kind
of um she's just been thrown for a loop
and she's trying to
um stabilize her life a bit um and I
just I just I love so many things about
her I love that she she's not very good
at
self-promotion so she she's very capable
but nobody really seems to understand
how capable she is she's not good at
selling herself um which I really
related to because that's something
that's so required as an actor and um
something I've just always been terribly
lousy at um and and so yeah it's the
kind of thing I sort of think of like
the actor experience of it is like
you're very good in the shower doing the
monologue but then you go to the
audition and it's comes out all wrong um
so throughout the process of the film
and the support with this this group
that she comes together with um she kind
of gets her groove back which um I'm
just excited to see what Joe's got in
store for her if she does actually get
her groove back in the coming
films a few moments ago I realized I was
standing here and I might be covering up
Ezra Miller and the internet will kill
me for that so Ezra tell us about uh
tell us about Credence sure um I guess
you could say Credence is sort of the
Aged Child Of
Violence um he's grown up partially in a
foster home where he still lives uh and
in a community uh
where uh there's um a prerogative to
Stamp Out uh a certain idea of what is
abnormal um and the rub lies in the fact
that Credence himself is abnormal
um and so as a result he's subject to uh
violence and sort of a violent form of
indoctrination um and I guess the
character is is sort of an exploration
of the resultant trauma um or or just as
simp it could also be stated more simply
like he he's just um a kid who hasn't
been loved or seen or cherished for who
he is it's heartbreaking it's a little
sad yeah is that yeah we're going to
open it up to questions on the floor and
um I'm not calling on people how is this
going to work you guys will do it
okay hi Nina Leal ceremony MC news this
is a question for you miss Rowling you
managed once again to stitch up a story
so full of emotions and I wonder how you
do it every time and if you actually
have a secret potion yourself that you
drink
beforehand um that's a really kind thing
to say you never know you're doing it
until it's done you never you never I
mean I I don't yet know what the
reaction to this movie will be I I am
proud of it that's the most you can say
as the Creator I think we all feel very
proud of what we've done together and if
you can say that you you can say
everything I would love for everyone
else to love it as much as we do but um
the sad truth is the boring answer
is it's a partly inspiration and it's
partly a lot of hard work that's it
always hi uh Mr rolling over here um
what would be a hardest decision to jump
on and create a brand new
universe or to not give all those fans
those Harry Potter fans and fans of
yours much more of this what would be
harder sorry I'm not sure I understood
the question what would it be harder to
to create a new universe or or not give
the fans more of this not give
well I've been aware since the end of
Harry Potter that there was still a huge
Hunger for
More and I think it would be easy to say
then I'll just keep producing that's but
I never was that person I planned seven
books I knew exactly what I wanted to
write and that story was finished but as
I said at the at the start of this conf
confence I always had some ideas about
new and I was intrigued by new and the
truth is that when I was asked will you
write more at the back of my mind was N
I thought well you know maybe that one
day and so here we are and I think
that's the best way this is what I
really really wanted to write this
hasn't been created in response
to a need or an awareness that I could
write more this has been created because
this is something I really wanted to
write and I hope that when people see
the movie they will understand that it
grew out of certain things that are very
important to me anywhere in the world at
the
moment hi Jakey rling this is Michael
joer from play bill um the film starts
with new coming from London to New York
and I think that what we're most curious
about is when New York audiences are
going to get to see cursed child and
when that will come and if um and if you
have anything else up your sleeve for
the stage if we'll see Fantastic Beasts
on the stage one day or any other
property I there are no plans to put
fantastic be on stage let us do the
movies okay first um kurur child we we
do very much hope it will come to
Broadway but we I have no dates to tell
you yet but certainly we we hope so we
hope it's going to come to Broadway
yeah hi um it's been confirmed that
Dumbledore is in the sequel I'm curious
in that movie will he be portrayed as
openly gay and will you explore his
romantic relationship with grindlewald
well no this is I'm very I'm very
comfortable with the question um I can't
tell you everything I would like to say
because this is obviously it's a
five-part story so there's
lots to unpack in that
relationship I will say that you will
see
Dumbledore as a as a younger man
and quite a troubled man because he
wasn't always the sage he was always
very clever and he was but we'll see him
at what I think was the formative period
of his
life um as far as his sexuity is
concerned um watch this space I would
say oh uh leading up to leading up to
the last question this is a two-part
question first one is for Joe and The
Davids how did you sort of evolve into
creating five movies like how did that
come about and the second movie is a
second question sorry is what was all
the actor's initial gut reaction when
you heard it was going to be five
movies I think I I'm going to let the
Davids talk a bit I seem to have been
talking a lot Davids do your
thing with a five movie thing um Joe Joe
Joe started with the first screenplay
and developing that first screenplay was
was uh it was a wonderful experience for
us because you were the material was
pouring out of Joe but it was tough as
well actually it's a tough process
writing a screenplay and um there was a
period I think where you were thinking
whether or not it was going to be more
than one screenplay Trilogy it was a
sort of process of I think we always
knew it was going to be a trilogy there
may have been dark moments where I
wondered where I whether I was going to
write it all yeah so there was a and
then towards the end of that first
script you said yes you want to write
through all three of them and then I
noticed as you've been writing too
there's been suddenly as The Works
pouring out you it sort of it was Joe
she said look I've got five stories here
so it it's her fault really she wants to
to to sort of take this ambitious
narrative and it is a very ambitious
narrative across five movies um in eight
years it's great and I would say for us
when we found out um that evening which
was a The Fan cast around the world so
much about this process has been so top
secret that it's top secret to us our
scripts were sent in put in safes at the
end of the day but all for a reason
which we understand which is there is
such an appetite for the world and the
universe and the stories that Joe
creates that keeps in this world of so
few surprises it's wonderful to try and
keep those Secrets but it was quite
embarrassing because I have a fear of
silence and when we were doing this um
General chat um there was a question
there was a sort of lull as we were all
on stage at this Fan cast and I was just
filling the Silence with absolute
gobbley go and and David was going Ed
shush shush Joe's here and we were
complet we were completely shocked that
she was here and when you announced it
was five it was absolutely shock to us
but such excitement
because when you work with JK Rowling
you know that her passion is her
characters and she is fiercely
protective of her characters and when
you are given
the responsibility of representing one
of those you feel so well protected
because it's almost like playing a real
person because you have all of the
resource and the imagination of Joe to
work with so it actually was it was
shocking and very exciting at the same
time I'm Fernando from Chile and I have
a couple of questions to JK first um of
course after the butter books you know
you started to experimenting with other
mediums uh the Poore side a play now a
screenplay was it a a decision of you to
uh stay away from the book route you
know and start to experiment in this
other medium and my other question is um
a more general question um what do you
think now when you I imagine that you
every now and then think and the impact
that your stories you know have had you
know in people of all ages and around
the
world well to take the second part
second question first um if I'm very
honest with you
I it is an enormous honor to to have
anyone one one individual say to you
your work has been a place of Refuge or
or it has been my Escape or it helped me
make sense of something often B I'm
often told that it made sense of
bereavement which is unsurprising even
the Potter books were were really
largely about
death having said that I try not to
focus too much on on what other people
think about the work it's healthy to be
interested in what other people think
because you learn from what people like
and don't like but ultimately you have
to be true to what you want to you want
to do the work that you want to produce
and I think it's a mistake almost to be
focus group driven as it were the first
part of your question um novels remain
my first love I'm still writing novels I
am this is why I look so tired I'm
writing a novel and a screenplay
currently so uh novels are my first love
but I if I if I hav't enjoyed ultimately
uh for all the for all the tricky bits
if I hadn't enjoyed writing the first
screenplay so much I I wouldn't have
said I'd keep writing so I am loving
it hi um I'm afraid this question is
going to get me obliviated so I'm going
to frame it carefully but I was
wondering sort of going forward um
you've obviously weaved the the lore
that we learned in the Harry Potter
series into this into Fantastic Beasts
in the series and I was wondering how
that's going to factor in going forward
especially when it comes to the strange
family what an interesting
[Music]
question um
David well I've been I'm under a strict
edict not to say too much actually from
Warner Brothers so I I'd like to be as
discreet as
possible um
David Katherine no no you know um I
think that and I've um read the second
script and it is beyond exciting and I
think the only thing that I can say is
that the connective tissue that you have
seen in this film is just the beginning
and that as the story
unfolds um I'm looking at Joe because
she can tell me if I'm wrong but as the
story unfolds those that connective
tissue to the Potter to what we know and
have seen and have read in seven books
and eight films will become more
explicit and um I think that what's so
wonderful about I think this film is
that it and what Joe has written is that
it can stand on its own you don't have
to have read a single Harry Potter book
course seen a single Harry Potter film
to enjoy it
and yet if you
have it's you there's a wonderful
additional experience of this story as
you continue that exper that that
ability to watch it without having seen
or read a Potter um will remain you will
be able to enjoy it but I think you will
enjoy them in an completely different
way with the with the experience of
having read and seen the Potter films
and books so
basically nothing you've got
nothing I have I I am not a dragon I
have told these actors quite a
lot yeah I
have from mugget um first off I want to
say that uh we did see the movie the
other night and speaking for a lot of
the fandom it's amazing we loved it
thank you they are going to love it too
so rest assured uh my question is for
the actors so many of you have worked
with Potter Talent um Ezra and Eddie
worked with Emma and Allison with Jason
um did you hear from them or talk to
them once you were cast and if you did
what did they say to
[Applause]
you uh yeah I mean Emma was the first
person I
called um you know it I think think
usually if you know someone who's worked
with anyone who you're about to work
with it seems rational to check in uh
and find out what you're um plunging
into and I I fortunately when I called M
I was given uh good news and uh she told
me what a a magical experience uh it was
um for her obviously in an enormous and
different way for her and in the context
of her life and um but particularly she
she
uh tried to prepare me for The Wonder of
David Yates um and help me to understand
that and you know I asked her I was like
yeah I met him and he seems so kind and
calm but when you start shooting that
must all fall apart and then he's
yelling at the department heads to get
the job done right she was like actually
Ezra no he will remain that calm through
the entirety of the production um which
is true and and an amazing thing about
David I remember having a conversation
with um R fees soon after i' been cast
and and similarly um he was talking
about David and saying the astonishing
thing is for the scale of the movies and
if you're directing a film of this size
and intricacy frankly with all of the
different departments and you are having
to guide this troller you know he said
what is astonishing for all the
different departments that he's having
to juggle he has the most astonishing
eye for actors as in he is on you and
seeing everything and if you look at his
early TV work and all of his work in the
the the the Potters that's absolutely
clear but what was astonishing to me is
that amidst the scale we he managed to
make it feel like an indie movie I know
that sounds ridiculous but he genuinely
did like he was seeing every ounce of
what we were doing and so that was
wonderful hi Erin from from mental
floss.com uh this question is for JK um
how did you decide which beasts you
wanted to include in the movie and then
how involved were you in the design of
the
creatures um the beasts were interesting
because I think we there were a couple
of the beasts that are in the movie were
always in the movie and then we swapped
a couple as we
went uh just because we thought it would
make a more
interesting there were some escapades we
wanted to put in so we swapped a couple
of beasts just felt better I don't want
to say too much but I think everyone's
going to want a nfler after this I want
a nfler quite honestly we all want
nflers um as far as the design was
concerned yeah I was involved and I I
saw everything we have the most
extraordinary creative team um they've
done such beautiful work on this movie
it's been amazing
yeah um hi this is a Jill Sergeant with
the reuter I have a question for JK
Rowling um you were very vocal yesterday
uh Joe about your feelings on the
election of Donald Trump and I wondered
if you could talk a little bit more
about how those feelings uh how how your
feelings about that election relate to
some of the themes in fantastic beast
and also in Harry
Potter I think I don't want to say any
more specifically about yesterday right
now because we're here for the movie
that we've all worked so hard on and I
you know I I would like to talk about
that and I think today might be a day to
concentrate on some good things and
putting some good things out into the
world hopefully um as far as themes are
concerned obviously this um this story
was conceived a few years ago so I I
can't make any direct relationship to
anything that happened yesterday but I
will say that um this first movie shows
how five the Five actors on stage of
playing five characters who were drawn
into a situation that none of them
expected and as often happened in the PO
ofers they they are going to have to
make some choices about how they deal
with something that you Glimpse for the
first time in this
movie um and that will obviously become
a significant factor going forward and
if you have read the Potter books you'll
know that this period in history
was uh threatened to become very
dystopian so you were looking at the
rise of a of of a very dark force but as
I say I I conceived this story a few
years ago and it was partly informed by
what I see as a a rise of
populism um around the world but I can't
say anything specifically about
yesterday because as I say I've been
planning this story a long
time I Robin Kansas with movie
hall.net um this is for all of you uh
regardless of role played in creating
Fantastic Beasts whether you an actor
producer director or writer um how much
fun was it working in this
multi-dimensional world where one second
you're in like 1920s New York and the
next second you're in a
suitcase it was amazing it was so much
fun it was this it was the what was most
wonderful was that we so much of had
been built so I'm I have a pretty shoddy
imagination and and what was so
wonderful I thought there was going to
be a huge am man of green screen and the
reality the reality was that a lot of
New York was built in Watford just
outside of London there were cars
brought over from here from the period
there was Smoke there was rising from
the streets if that it was a sensory
overload but then beyond that working
with the creatures they would gave us
the freedom to play in rehearsal and
work out what we needed so sometimes we
had some some puppet who had worked on
warhorse created a huge three-man puppet
for the arant we had uh we had then kind
of almost not quite animatronic but
really Grizzly slightly
disgusting gelatin things for the mylaps
and and it was like there were moments
there were moments when we
just you had to access your inner kid
and and I loved every single moment of
that it's like me and Charlie in the
Chocolate
Factory and we all got a golden ticket
man and uh it's like winning a lottery
also everybody um because
obviously these three are such
extraordinary people and so in addition
to Bringing together obviously the most
imaginative and talented uh crew as they
could everybody has to be kind because
if if you're not then you you just one
One Bad Apple can ruin the bunch and and
so you know you just you just felt safe
enough to play and to take risks and and
you felt like everybody was in it with
you and and there was just this really
beautiful mood on set so it it actually
felt like a magical Universe to walk
into you came in and you felt like okay
today we're we're living in a in a dream
you know and um and that influenced
everything I think that there's a
there's a tremendous amount of heart in
this film and it's because we all we all
were allowed to to feel the amount of
love that we could you know we weren't
we weren't um we didn't have to protect
ourselves on the set which was a really
beautiful
thing tomb from AFP uh I was just that's
a question for JK I was just wondering
uh I heard that you went through several
drafts of the screenplay and some of
them being very dark I was just
wondering one of them was really dark
there was a there was a lot of stuff in
the sewers I don't know I don't know
what was going through I don't know what
was going on in my life at that moment I
just remember David saying this is very
dark he's he's never here's everything
everyone's saying about David is so true
he's so kind and so measured this is
this is a very dark draft like you know
dot dot dot yeah you you need to lighten
up a little so um yeah we went through a
lot of drafts but that actually is
always is always my process this isn't a
screenwriting thing I tend to generate a
lot of material and then I will and some
some of the ideas from some of those
drafts I'm sure will be in the following
movies that just seems to be how I work
I just keep generating a lot of
material hi Ally from People magazine um
I wanted to ask it's kind of a two-part
question Miss Rowling can you talk about
the pressures of the fan expectation of
going back into the potterverse and then
for the actors as well the pressures of
like fans uh being so excited that it's
coming um kind of living up to those can
you talk a little about uh the fan
reaction so far that you've
gotten well no one's seen the movie yet
so the the the uh the fan reaction that
I've seen has spanned a lot of uh
different responses I suppose I can't
wait for people to see it you know what
I I really can't we're very proud of
what we've made and um it's you know
this is just the beginning it's it's a
five-part movie I know which characters
are coming next and I
know why are you laughing at that
there's someone really
Co well I I know what's coming so this
is chapter one and uh I think people
will like what's coming I hope so I'm
I'm not going down the sewers though I
was I I read between the lines there
there's not a big market for spending a
lot of time in the sewers apparently
anyway that everyone else needs to
answer your other
question
oh sorry but there was a question for
the expectations well nobody knows our
characters yet so that's a little bit of
a um a welcome break in in in that we do
know that this is such a beloved world
and you've are you've created these
characters that we all fell in love with
in the Potter books and we all had a
very Vivid and understanding of who they
were before the movies came out and
thankfully they were brilliantly cast
and so we were all relieved um but I
think we're extra relieved in that
nobody knows our characters yet so you
didn't have a preconceived idea of them
but um I I think we've all seen fans
have been really welcoming and really um
lovely to us which is great because you
know you don't we're the new kids and um
you never know when somebody loves
something so much it's like you know if
somebody makes a record and and you're
like I love that album don't make
anymore make some more don't make
anymore it's never going to be the same
but keep going and you're just like what
do you supposed to do but but um there
there is this like real real warmth and
and and hunger as you said for more and
I think we're really excited to share
these characters that we all loved so
much with with you guys yeah they said
when at Comic-Con they they just kept on
saying welcome to the family and that's
so sweet it's really
nice I like to say that I was um scared
because as a big Harry Potter fan I felt
like I was running the risk of um being
compelled to loathe myself because if I
were to disappoint Harry Potter fans I
would have to join their ranks as is my
tendency so yeah it was a little
daunting certainly a little daunting I
was so nervous when when when we first
started and like sort of like Tina was
trying to act like I had it more under
control than I did and I got to set and
I sort of summoned all my courage and I
thought I had a Brit Brave face on and
everyone kept asking me if I was all
right so I started to think um I must be
really giving away a lot more than I
thought and
uh then I the third or fourth person
asked me if I was all right and I went
and I looked in the mirror like did I
have something on my face or did I look
really ill or and then after about five
or six people said are you all right I
noticed them saying it to each other and
it's just how they greet each other in
England in the
morning hey yeah are you all right yeah
are you all right
I always get really defensive was like
yeah why yeah the New Yorker comes out
and you're like yeah what's your
[Laughter]
problem yeah I can just to what Ezra
said we were all such fans of the books
and the
films of course you don't want to be the
guy that comes along and schmuck that
comes and sort of ruins it so there was
definitely this there was a sense of
expectation on ourselves that we put in
but I think that galvanizes you and I
think it makes you work harder and um
and the people around us created this
environment in which it it that actually
disappeared while we were making the
film and we felt free to play and to
come up with ideas and to re a great
really great freedom and it was only
when we started doing press that
everyone was like how you feeling it's
quite a lot of pressure right there that
we just sort of started gently sweating
and have been for the past few weeks so
thanks
hello not to make you any more nervous
than you were
before I'm from The Leaky cauldron I'm
Katherine horbath I am a fan it was
great but it's been 9 years since the
last Potter and 5 years since the last
movie do you have any words of
encouragement for the hardcore fans that
are still skeptical I know that half of
you are Harry Potter fans and half of
you created it do you have any words of
encouragement for those who are hesitant
that they're that this world that they
they also feel protective of is coming
back and coming back in an offshoot with
nothing to do with
Harry
well
okay it's true that Harry's not in the
movie cuz he's not born
yet but this is very much of the
world and there are char
ter you will learn more
about um through fantastic Beast I'm
being so careful you know this is Potter
there's a certain glory in writing a
standalone novel where you can just say
anything you want you know now I'm back
in top secret territory again but um as
far as reassurance
goes I think we've done the very best
job we can and I certainly have told a
story I really wanted to tell and I
can't think of any better reason to tell
a story and I hope that people love it I
think that we've got a cast with more
chemistry than I could have dreamt of
they've just this the people up here and
other members of our cast too have
produced such extraordinary work on this
movie and it touches me to hear what
Allison just said about the kindness
because I think everyone I'm still in
touch with so many people from the
Potter movies
and they all have such happy memories of
that time we all do it was a family and
what Dan just said as well about his
reception at ComicCon you know this has
been a very generous vandom in many many
many ways and I hope they take these
guys to their hearts as much because I
think they really deserve
it can you talk a bit about the
importance of friendship in your stories
how we've gone from this Unforgettable
tree of the Harry poter important movies
to this quartet that we have now and
also how your characters seem to be
Outsiders and unlikely
Heroes um we definitely do have an
unlikely hero in N who goes to New York
and in some senses he's every man he
gets drawn into something as we all do
in life that he wasn't planning to to
become part of um but he is very much
Outsider also he's as Eddie says so
truly new isn't really a guy who has a
lot of friends he's very British he's uh
he needed to go to America to be taught
um that people were
likable so no would you think that's
fair comment new's not a he's not really
a people guy he's much more comfortable
with things that are spiky and
fanged and uh he meets his antithesis in
Jacob Co I who is who is the most
likable naturally likable guy but who
doesn't really realize what he's got
Jacob doesn't really think he's a big
deal um so that was a a very interesting
idea to me and that's the basis for our
friendships in this so it's a quartet
rather than a trio in this movie um
which was fun to write it was fun to
have two big female roles as well I I
really enjoyed write and I enjoyed
writing sisters you know I'm one of a
pair of sisters one of a pair of sisters
so you know I won't say too much more
cuz I want to be able to go home
unscathed don't don't shoot the
messenger but this is the last question
JK Cindy prman from The New York Times
Syndicate uh two questions one your
story is just as magical to people as
what you write just say a few words for
people who are trying to get into
writing and or facing hard times and
second can you just give us a glimpse
into your writing process is it mornings
or late nights or how do you do it
um as far as writing is concerned I need
to do
it I feel strange if I don't
write um clearly I don't need to write
anymore and I love it so much it it
would feel
like almost some sort of psychic utation
if I if I if I if I didn't so you know
basically I have to write um as far as
hard times are
concerned
um I never forget how incredibly
fortunate I am I genuinely I get up
every day and I think I do the thing I
love I have a wonderful family I I am
I'm the luckiest person I know and I
would wish the same for everyone who is
who is out there working hard and trying
to deal with life which is tricky for
all of us no matter who we are um and my
writing process well I I will say that
we flew we flew out here yesterday
evening I can write
anywhere at any time and I think I serve
quite a hard apprenticeship as a lone
parent you know when I really decided I
was going to finish that first book and
try um I can write with the TV on in the
background I can write half answering my
kids questions I have written a
surprising amount of one chapter
actually on the lavat
tree which was the only place I could
get temporary
piece and last night I was in a kind of
oblique mood boarding the plane and I
thought I need to work so I got out the
second screenplay and I did some work on
that and that made me feel a whole lot
better so I can write all the time
anytime thank
you